just so that the record is very very
clear
Angela Johnson has no rights to Chloe
her rights were terminated she has been
legally adopted and I have read some of
the comments to where people have said
sweetie you've waited 10 years too late
that is correct Chloe's not going to
Angela Angela doesn't have any rights to
her Todd and Julie Chrisley make their
stance clear after their adopted
daughter Chloe's biological mom
suggested she wants Chloe back I don't
care what you say about me but if you
come at my kids or you come about my
wife oh gosh then I'm gonna drag you
last week Chloe's biological mom Angela
Johnson told TMZ she plans to go back to
court and get Chloe back home claiming
she was cut out of her daughter's life
and now Todd and Julie are speaking out
about it on their Chrisley confessions
podcast it's ironic that her biological
mother would come forward now when she
has not been in her life since 2015 and
her rights Angela Johnson surrendered
her parental rights
um March of 2017 and we never heard from
her again Chloe was legally adopted by
myself and by Julie and she is legally
our child and we will be the ones who
decide if and when the time comes as to
who will be her caregiver well she is
just precious as can be she's the boss
she truly is she is the boss the 10 year
old is actually taught in Julie's
granddaughter the child of Todd's son
Kyle from a previous marriage
I have officially raised children my
entire life
and just I was that close to a clean
getaway and then all of a sudden here
comes my club bug knocking on the door
we're starting over she has that
Chrisley we call it Chrisley too
um she has that chrisly attitude Todd
and Julie obtained custody of Chloe amid
Kyle's struggles with addiction the
couple originally shared parental duties
with Angela but the Chrisleys were
awarded soil custody in 2017 after
Angela was arrested for allegedly filing
a false application for Medicaid Angela
Johnson gave her she literally
surrendered her rights to her child
she did this in front of a judge the
judge explained to her you understand
what you're doing you understand that
you have surrendered the rights and
you're surrendering the rights of your
child and then explained that she had x
amount of days to come back in and
rescind that and despite Todd and Julie
facing prison time 12 and seven years
respectively after being found guilty of
tax fraud they vowed to do what's best
for Chloe which they say is staying with
their family Chloe's family is who Chloe
has been raised with and Chloe is a very
bright intelligent
charismatic funny beautiful child who
has a heart of compassion and her life
is going to be as unaltered as it
possibly can be based on what Julie and
I have the ability to to control
foreign